[Music]
uh
[Music]
ain't no competition in the ring or
cipher cause i'm spitting financial
swing of fire talking pickled peppers
make them pay the piper cause i might go
look like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a food reduction you'll
be talking like you want a new
concussion to do the custom attitude
adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sound which i will serve having
tipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
capping you a phony homie now you owe me
action have him sinking tony tony tony
braxton and they all want to talk for
attention but the fame only lasts for an
instant mama got a hand so i'm ready for
the tension i'ma leave him ready you can
dance to redemption
[Music]
see that there we go we are outside
everybody hear me nice and clear let's
go
let me see
get that out of there
that's the restream box
got six watching let's get it
let's definitely get it we yo we so
uh
we got anton gary antoine uh
russell
and
he
he just scored the knockout which is
kind of crazy man which is absolutely
kind of crazy
i wanted to see this uh undercard so bad
because i love
um
the russell brothers
uh
i gotta give much respect to uh the
father
you know who passed away
rest in peace you raise kings you have
raised kings
so
oh what's good dan
is that dan that's don
yeah what's going on don that's what's
you the first one then yo let me tell
you something right now um
one of the reasons why i wanted to see
this uh fight
is because of the undercut i um
uh antoine uh gary antoine uh russell uh
that's uh gary russell jr's brother
i think i think he's a truly a monster
and um he's fighting uh bartholomew
and
he just knocked about that on me out
i literally thought this was gonna be
the fight before the main event
and um
it is what it is
but
man uh it was a slugfest um
140 it this this this i i can't lie
so uh thank you for joining the
professional fan
uh lord king david iron lords podcast
yo what's going on this is facebook uh
user what y'all slipping on that's the
question right now i made a blue
hawaiian
there you go
so um
yes yes queen oh my dude you made it
brother did you see the bartholomew
fight with uh um
uh gary antoine russell
yo
i'ma tell you right now
he's he's one of the dudes to look out
for it don't matter if it's a clean
fight if it's a dirty fight uh it's a
rough fight
that boy comes to fight his father
raised some serious dogs man
yo
that was that was one of the reasons why
i wanted to watch this card this that
this is one of the reasons
um
besides you know danny garcia last time
i seen danny garcia you know um yeah
he's he's he's a dog ben for sure the
last time i saw danny garcia
he was in there with my boy spence
and
spence made him keep his hands at bay
you know he wasn't throwing them hands
like you know we know uh danny the
counterpunch he's a good counter puncher
spence was doing things to danny that
made danny not want to
um throw those hands
and
the last time i saw
jose benavidez
he was fighting crawford
so
i don't think
you know um you know he got knocked out
with crawford
he was doing his best but he had an
injury to his leg so i don't know really
what's going to happen in this fight
this is a really a 50 50 fight
yeah he he definitely spence definitely
made danny look average he made him look
basic
but spence makes a lot of dudes look
basic he even made porter look basic at
times in that fight but i think he
wanted to dominate porter i think he
wanted to break porter i think i think
spence has a problem
with wanting to uh
beat somebody at their game
what up sharon
that's right that's right what y'all
simping on put what you sipping on in
the chat right now man i told you i made
a blue hawaiian
special little bit of malibu in there
everybody know my little secret recipe
too
definitely i know y'all like whoa that's
blue blue yeah that's blue blue that's
smurf blue had a little bit of smurfs
grab a little smurfs and squeeze them
get get in there get in and get in there
little gargamel smell
yo um um
and to see
uh gary russell jr
taking over in the corner
water that's what's up
to see him taking over in the corner
from his uh from normally what his pops
does
i'm gonna tell you right now i know this
was a heavy heavy
heavy camp for um
antoine uh russell i know it was i know
it was
y'all drink water diddy definitely
definitely
orange crush orange crush that's what's
up
yo the overhand right i think
bartholomew could have definitely went a
little bit longer i'm gonna be honest
with you um
i think that was an early stoppage ah
man but that's what happens when you are
so hyped for a fight
so
i'm really hyped for this fight i think
uh i think i think bullfighter is at the
precipice of a crossroads to be honest
with you um because both of them are
coming off the losses
and
or major major fights at major losses
is it me
or um
oh yeah shout out to sms audios yeah
yeah 50 give me that money i think 50
sold them to i think 50 sold them
i could have got the bag before then i i
was messing with 50 i brought every last
color that's when it was you know the
battle of sms audio versus beats
um i like the sturdiness of uh sms audio
to be honest with you
oh
hard to find what's good yo what's going
on
um you got adrian broner versus figueroa
excuse me august 20th um
another fight and it needs to let his
hands go
i think i think
spence made uh danny gun shy
with throwing those punches danny danny
was in peril of getting knocked out in
that fight and he knew it so you know
his father was yelling yo throw those
hands throw those hands and i think
that's the first time i've ever seen
danny
not engage in the manner that he
normally engaged when he fought keith
thurman he engaged when he fought sean
porter he engaged yeah danny's a slow
starter but when when it heats up he
engages and and
danny
weighs heavy on his chin right he knows
that he can take your punch he'd have
philly that philly in them that philly
and him get him deep into the fight
what's going on what's going on
ruiz what's going on
rules
where can you watch the fight on the app
get that showtime map you got um
[Music]
these are heavyweights that's coming up
now
and um
i think uh this heavyweight is out of
new york you have uh
the
american he's not from new york right um
but i know the polish uh
fighter
he has a huge contingent in new york
city
and um
i i i i watch the fights through the
apps
and and you know
streaming apps or whatever you know
quick quick easy
um part of show time just hit the
pay-per-view button
and then you win
um yeah adam kowatski
um
he he he hits he's he's a little
doughboy looking
but he got good hand skills like don't
be fooled by these chubby dudes these
chubby dudes out there can put them paws
on you
start hitting you with those joints
making sweat pop off the top of your
head you really understand who you
messing with in that ring
but i think you know he has a huge
content this this is in new york city by
the way this fight is at the barclays
center you know brooklyn stand up the
barclay center quickly became the home
of boxing like took an elbow to the face
you know msg took an elbow to the face
from the barclay center i think they had
an edict out there that they wanted to
make this the town of fighting and they
wanted brooklyn to be the home of the
knuckle busters you know let me see
let's go on
that's right
oh reddit streams don't do that don't do
that don't do that support support them
dudes man stop playing around like that
get out of there with that
queen oh i wish i could hit you with the
with the dm right now i'm in the middle
yeah he takes too many shots and he
needs to clean
he need to clean up that defense
what what i do like about him though
is he does slip a lot of shots right
and if he starts to put his hands
because he places his punches in in
spots
if you notice that you know um
he's a little slick he's a little doughy
um i think he what they call him the
fighting pizza dude or something like
that because he works in a pizza shop
uh old boy is definitely nice with those
mitts i remember i was surprised with
one of his fights um i saw it live
and i was truly surprised with his hand
speed
because it's different it doesn't
translate when you're watching they
pretty much sold out the barclay pretty
much sold out the barclay all the um
the the uh upper rim
uh seats uh the the private booths they
they are all packed out right now and i
see downstairs is packed out i i love
that man i'm not gonna lie i love the
fact that you know sitting in person
with people uh boxing is back and
uh
i know i know you know some places you
gotta wear masks but new york city and
some of the indoor events is not so
what up what up who that yeah steve
jersey what uh what up still
yeah yeah share that out [ __ ] that out
we got a uh 14 now he's gonna pack up
he's gonna pack up soon as uh
danny and this boy gets up in there
um
i i think um
he's he's really different he's
deceptive in his movements don't a lot
of those punches that look like they
clean aren't clean on them because he
tucks his head so a lot of times he lets
it slip off the top and say you see how
you know my hair right there is a
a little wet look greasy so
it slips off you know he slips in he
slips in he slips he dips and he does a
lot of shoulders so when he's putting
his shoulder in
he catches the the punch here and it
slides over so don't think that he takes
a lot of those shots uh flush
now if you're a heavy puncher
and you catch him on the distance of
your shot
uh that could affect him because he's an
inside fighter to be so doughy he's an
inside fighter and that's that's kind of
crazy let me see
yeah danny garcia's from philly yup yup
yup
yeah yeah yeah
danny danny
danny is uh
uh
prototypical philly fighter
but what i didn't like about what he
what his excuses that he was making
right now
uh for
the spins fight of him losing
he started saying oh the pandemic had
affected him and
that um he was having anxiety and all
this other crap
um yo
could you imagine what spence was
thinking when
he uh
came back off the car accident danny was
a top fighter that didn't have any
injuries
and we all know i mean a lot of those
injuries weren't disclosed from spence
but he had a ton of injuries
and um you know to come back from that
and actually get up in there with a a
rank five uh contender come on man
that's something different that's that's
a beast of a man so if if you don't have
spence making excuses and i don't think
he would have made excuses if he lost
don't make no no excuses you just lost
to the better man at night when you walk
in the ring he's going to be win lose a
draw
so you know and you came up on the short
under the stick [ __ ] through your hands
more you know if you thought
that you had a a better thing
so right now
these heavyweights they they're in the
middle ring they're throwing punches so
both of them are a little bit doughy
so you got
cuz
kawaki
and
darmian is in
and thermizing is uh he's sticking
behind his jab he has a high guard
and uh kozaki is moving back and forth
he does a lot of body work for somebody
that big
he does a lot of bodywork
excuse me
still getting over this uh the vid you
know so
i love
what he does how he places his shots he
moves out the way he uses his feet to
actually slide out of the way so what
they're doing right now they're in the
center of the ring and you know they're
jabbing exchanging jabs and kazaki is uh
um hitting them
with the body shots and he's he's trying
to bring the one two and bring the third
over the top
uh i think what he should do is place
the third to the mid and uh get him get
uh there's end to drop his hands down a
little bit lower but derezen knows that
uh
kanaki
drops his left
and he's throwing overhand right trying
to catch him so he he would try to throw
overhand right here and there these
these are pretty good adobe guys right
you know if you want two big guys
fighting this is a real like uh ballroom
fighting if you've ever been to ballroom
fighting got your little drinks got your
little bed got your little pizza or
whatever you sitting there watching
ballroom fights it's dope as hell let me
see
don't want to see thurman
yeah there's too many champions right
now
let me tell you something
i would blame
crawford
if this fight doesn't happen with spence
versus crawford i'ma solely put the
blame on crawford's neck
um because at the end of the day
you said all this crap in the beginning
that you would take less to fight spins
you want spence you think spence is that
dude that can you you're gonna beat him
and you said all the stuff now right now
spence told you after he
uh got a hold of uh
uh olga's got that belt
he coming for you
first person he said yo who you gonna do
none of that him and huh you know who i
want that belt come up off that belt my
dream is to knock you the hell out and
get that belt and it has nothing to do
with the actual person because he was
saying the same stuff to keith thurman
when keith thurman was running and
ducking and hiding you don't forget
keith thurman had two of those belts and
earl had one and he was going after
keith he was like yo what's up i've been
wanting those belts for a minute
it has nothing to do nothing personal i
think that man has just a tunnel vision
and i think that has to do with derrick
james derek james puts a tunnel vision
in these dudes or sees whatever their
desire is and help them achieve their
desire all right because you got to say
that to jamelle jamel had a desire to
become a unified uh um 154 uh what is
that super welterweight champion
and he did it
he stuck to it and he did it so you you
got to really say to yourself um
what is crawford waiting for
is do you do you want rematch clauses
remember if you're the biggest baddest
best like you said floyd this is the
reason why i love floyd
floyd said he was the biggest baddest
best right always right
and floyd put it on the line when he was
trying to fight oscar he gave oscar all
advantages the back end of the money the
front end of the money the gloves the
the ref the the judges everything
whatever you needed to win he gave it to
him and said let's get it on
you know and a lot of these champions
had to take the short end of the stick
to to actually gain look at devin hayney
devin haney just did it to become
undisputed and fighting cam bosses he
just did that he just gave the short end
of the stick
in order to win at the long end and what
did he do he went out there and whacks
the hell out of cambosis
so i'm god in there man like
what are we looking here for what what
are we waiting here for
you know um i think crawford listens and
he reads too much of his tabloids and i
honestly you did nothing in the 147 era
right now now he was doing stuff down at
140 was good you was universal uh
champion over there you had all the
belts and stuff down there you know uh
and fighting dongle and
you get all the belts whoop dee doo man
you did it you did it shout out shout
out it wasn't no big banger you wasn't
no headlining and no pay-per-view she
wasn't doing that you're not holding the
weight
so the fact that spence is holding away
he headlined in uh pay-per-views he's
selling out a cowboys arena get that man
his money and go get in there and whip
his behind if you really think you can
beat him if you really think you that
man if that switch hit a blood killer
get out their butt and do your thing man
shut everybody up
let this fight happen in november
my money on spence regardless
i don't care what type of shape you show
up in i think that boy is a killer
straight up i don't don't be fooled by
the baby face don't be fooled by the
kids in the ring don't be fooled by any
of that that man flipped out of a
ferrari going over 100 miles an hour got
up and and he fighting daddy got seeing
next and taking his situation
no man on god man no no no that's a
that's a man to be fed like you saw it
yo
think about it this way
and i know crawford looked at it this
way
you see
what happens to everybody this wild dude
unfaced
where are they after the fact
like after the fact like what are you
doing after the fact
sean porter after the fact uh
contemplating retirements
um danny garcia didn't come back to the
ring until now
um
kell brook he was just a shell of
himself right after that after he broke
the other side of his face shell himself
oogaz hasn't been heard of since
no no interviews no nothing no
conversation wouldn't that be the dude
to have all the interviews after that
you just fought this guy like wouldn't
you do that
so come on now like on god like
you really gotta this dude's a he's a
destroyer of men
and i'm pretty sure bud saw that and i'm
pretty sure but was hanging around all
his little friends at
the um hall of fame boxing hall of fame
and they sitting there blowing his head
up gassing them up you the greatest
incites bread
you okay but
i respect everything that bud does i
just don't think
i mean
dudes fight after bud
you know um but don't bud hasn't ruined
nobody
dudes fight after bud
i think sean porter did him a favor be
honest with you
that that's my boy and i'm about to go
out man real quick check it out like if
i'm the champion right oh i'm a former
champion i got a name and i'm in this
division i mean requiem will fight and
i'm like yo
yo i'm about to be out of here me let's
let's get this bread together
me and him chop it up that's my boy we
we chop it up let's get this bread
together
you know because that's what you do for
your peoples you get bread
so my man gonna get that money
yeah crawfish fight at 147 unforgettable
honestly yo also yo hit that uh cash app
fund me that's real like that's real the
phone number ain't real because the
phone number we're not gonna be in this
environment right we ain't gonna be in
this environment super chat is good uh
hit the hit that uh the the cash app
that's definitely real um
but the calling that's about to happen
everything is almost completely done
like upstairs so i don't even want to be
in this room this is the iron lords
media room that i'm in be honest with
you
upstairs is a little chill out situation
is a nice situation got a nice
screen panel screen and all this other
stuff and um nice pc
up there i i have to work on the camera
situation i think my
i got my old school camera i ain't got
this little luscious jaunt right here
like that um i have to fix that but um
yeah definitely uh it's gonna be
something nuts
something nuts and and then you're gonna
get a chance to see other statues right
now because y'all see these i forgot to
turn the lights on over there they get
the chance to see these statues y'all
you're not going to get a chance to you
can you got to see the other stuff you
know you got to see the other rooms
there's other rooms there's other rooms
here you know
but the media room right now they're in
the third round
and um you know i really i'm gonna call
the main fight right now we getting we
we catching up with each other we seeing
what's up with each other
let me see let me see
uh huh
let me see uh any statues from comic-con
that caught your hiking yo
the the statues okay so a couple of
statues that comic-con caught my eye the
one statue that i did see that i did
like was the xm studios
um
venom
let me see if i could pull that up right
now because i have it i was showing that
to a boy in my room
um
me and him was talking
let me see here here
if y'all can see it
is the xm studios of venom
looks dope looks absolutely crazy
uh i have one venom i had the sideshow
venom so maybe i might have to uh
get rid of it
and uh switch it off what do you think
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
talk but thank you for tuning in i
actually love you let me see
want to see my boy wilder back in the
ring he's definitely coming
mike nice comparison better winky catch
yeah yeah
um
no you have uh
uh ruez he's fighting uh ortiz
so russ is gonna fight ortiz
and after that
uh deontay might have a smaller tune-up
me personally if i'm guiding deontay i'm
gonna tell deontay to have a tune-up i'm
gonna check his mental going into a
fight i mean it's very hard to sleep on
silk sheets and satin sheets
excuse me and then get up
and fight you know to go do road work
i've never seen deontay wilder do road
work honestly i think that's his
downfall i think that that falls into
his stamina
um
i think if he actually did that and
don't rely heavily on the punch
that he would have more later on but um
ruiz versus ortiz
i
uh that's a hard one too
that's another 50 50 fight for me let me
see
yeah
let me see let me see
you know i i don't i don't think
he would mess with mayweather because of
the fact that um
how mayweather is cozy with anthony
joshua
mayweather and anthony joshua was like
that like
anytime mayweather is in england anthony
joshua was with him anytime they in
dubai anthony joshua's there like
um
i honestly don't think uh mayweather
would uh that that will work out for for
deonte
what i would like to see is
um sugar hill
sugar hill teach deontay how to fight
tall
sugar hill can actually teach deontay to
fight at his height
don't give up his his length um ha
actually fight on the inside actually
know how to turn the dude to put him
into position to punch him
um
didn't he just change teams anthony
joshua i believe so i believe anthony
joshua changed teams
but we won't know anything because he's
about to fight usak right he uh
initiated his trap card
shout out to attic
so um yeah i think uh anthony joshua
he has a long road back i don't i don't
know how the hell he beats usyk because
i think usyk has more confidence going
into the second fight
than he does in the first fight so
you're going to look at that you're
going to you're going to give
oh wilde yeah wild but wilder changed
his um his team
not his whole team
wilde changed uh his team when he got
rid of um
[Music]
who was his trainer that uh mark bralen
when he got rid of box breeland
remember um
he he
kind of threw mark breelan under the bus
for that uh second loss so you know
yeah
you're right you're right still yeah he
did he is like he he threw mark breelan
under the bus
he really just threw one dude under the
bus like it was his fault
i honestly i would have just told a man
you you really have to train like a
boxer he is an olympic boxer
it's a it's very hard to tell somebody
who's been successful
his whole life
we're doing it one way
to yo now you have to go this way to do
it you know you've been doing it this
way oh but we want you to switch and go
do it this way it's it's very hard
to get that into a a man a grown man's
head
right um
that's rich he got rich off of it he got
rich off of doing it his way
yeah yeah
um he has a lot left heavy weights are
different than other boxes
excuse me
yeah um heavyweights are
different than the lighter weights the
lighter weights really go and train like
have you seen like um
how pacquiao trains how floyd trains
these dudes put their body through a
level of punishment to achieve
these goals because they have to make
weight
remember that's another thing over the
head whatever their weight limit is is
over their head so
these dudes have to be in heavy
condition they have to make weight and i
think it's more competition in the
lighter weight classes the heavier
weight classes yeah that's the darling
of of the sport
and
all you need to do is be honest with you
you need to have one good gimmick that
works deonte wilder's one good gimmick
that works is that right hand boy he put
that right hand on your head
sleepy time for floyd
you got to really think about it he even
caught uh fury with a left hook
that dropped them
so
all those times that he dropped fury he
felt that he was close you can't
you can't teach somebody
that their style or whatever they're
using is wrong
when
they've been doing it and they've been
making them money you know let me see
let me see
yeah too much on power
yo
you yeah chocolatito is crazy
you gotta really
think if if if he never was a believer
he was a believer in his power
that's what kept him standing up those
all that time
you understand that's what kept him
taking those shots because he believed
that the next shot that he landed on you
is is is the fight that it can turn the
fight and it has happened for him how
many times have he been down deontay
wilder in fights and then
boom shakalaka
so
you can't say that his his his beliefs
aren't founded in fact his beliefs are
founded in fact it's just how many times
you're gonna go to the well before you
really find out that you don't got
nothing there shout out to sith lord
what's going on
you know what we doing you know what we
doing tonight everybody drinks up i told
y'all drinks free first first cake 1k
drinks free go on your refrigerator i
place the drink in there that's for you
i'm like santa claus i'm like santa
claus it's different it's like santa
claus but like what who who just left
the house ding-ding-ding me
but right now they're in the fifth round
and
the fifth round looks just like the
first round uh
uh two guys that if they actually did
the road work and actually restricted
their eating and then a lot of things
could have got the other guy out of here
a long time ago
but um yeah they're just exchanging
punches and hoping the next do fall
they're actually in the center of the
ring and if you if you like boxing like
this then this is this is great i call
this butter bean boxing if anybody uh
knows butter bean or you don't know
butter bean go look it up i call it
butter bean boxing you know you stand
and you just slug on them until they
fall out yeah there is some nuances to
it man so
let me see
oh thank you thank you thank you thank
you so much mom my wife my wife did this
doing water that's what's up
that's right that's right that's right
you take it easy
i i drive all week long
the only day i have off is saturday
i'm going to have me
one drink
i'm and i'm going to make the best drink
that i can absolutely make
so
yo they have thrown over 900 punches so
far on this fight and this is what this
is this is this is what people come to
see they go ugas who guys is that the
fight
and and i i'm i'm curious
to
what he has to say
because i thought the dude had more left
if they talking about he's in retirement
that's kind of crazy
and what type of man
is that like like what type of man is
suspense to put that young man into
retirement
because ugas
you you don't think
him getting that belt him putting on
that performance with spence actually
fighting with spence
actually you know uh taking that that
beating and actually being there
standing up not complaining
um because anybody could have looked for
the door out when he broke the orbital
socket anybody could have looked for the
door out when he broke the jaw anybody
could look for the door out when he
broke the rib anybody could have looked
for the door at any one of those moments
but that man stood there and he took he
he earned his paycheck like
think about it
he was in a slow car crash
a slow car crash could you imagine going
into a car crash
mad slow hell no i don't sign up for
that i don't want that i don't want that
at all
all right so kawaki is against the ropes
and um
dermis is is throwing the jab and he
keeps throwing the sweeping left hook in
the overhand right
and you know and he needs hitting kazaki
he's backing him up
and and i understand i think i think
sean said this that kozaki takes too
many shots
i think after a period of time
the ability to slip shots when you don't
do the amount of rule work you're
supposed to do
is is is going to worry on you
all right so tank versus ryan i don't
think that fight happens i think oscar
de la hoya
and uh you know ryan's team
knows that the equity is in ryan not
losing
the equity is in uh and ryan staying
undefeated
cherry pick your way all the way until
you're forced into a corner you know you
got shakur and you know you have haney
and you have a
tank
and sorry to say it's you know it's the
the black fighters that actually
have to
go out there and go go fight you know
like go go mix it up go fight um
there's a huge contingent in california
latino americans
and mexicans that are from mexico that
actually support
uh garcia ryan is uh a huge commodity
right so
for for what tank has built
as a following
because he everybody thinks that he
looks like the second coming of mike
tyson right
um okay
you can you can say that
and he's captivated audiences by his
knockouts and stuff like that and in the
time he didn't knock out um
uh isaac pitbull
he they they was like oh it was a close
fight
really wasn't that close but
you have to see that he built something
crazy there different level of
competitions i don't think um
ryan
fights i am uh uh isaac picked bill cruz
i i want to see that
like i want to see him take these fights
these step up fights
to show me that he's ready for tank i
don't think that he earned that spot to
fight tank to be honest with you he
hasn't even gotten a title yet this dude
has been
a title contender forever
he has been on the list and he has the
ability to have that fight necromancer
zeal was good baby thank you for showing
up
yeah yeah
i'm i'm not going to say that the the
black fighters are the drawers in boxing
i'm talking about fighters or the
drawers in boxing because
um
these undercards are filled with uh
universal fighters from all over
like
you you i love cuban fighters
i love
cuban fighters i love their basic
thoughts and fundamentals they train
from small to have the fundamentals so
if if if you ever ask me
what if if i had to watch a group of
fighters for a very long period of time
what group of fighters would be it will
probably be cubans first
then after that it would probably be
mexican-americans mexican mexicans
period because
julio cesar chavez i was a huge fan of
julio cesar chavez rest in peace sweet
pea um sweet pea is one of my good
friends
he he knows like i truly respect the
julio cesar chavez i don't give a [ __ ]
basically excuse my french if he fought
cab drivers
this dude
record was crazy at a time when people
wreck it wasn't that crazy like you know
he
60 70 100
this dude was a monster like an absolute
monster in that ring i saw what he did
to meldrick taylor so
um nah man i'm gonna say we all
represented inside the in in in the
bunch of uh as fighters go but some of
the most prominent fighters could be
african-americans they have a different
style they have a slick style
uh so that that's maybe what you
gravitate to me i gravitate to mexican
style fighting like real mexican
hard-nosed style
fighting um
i love that um and then
prince and i see him i met
you i i i'm a fool for that dude so it's
a lot of fighters that i actually love
and the different demographics from all
over the place um so yeah nah i i can't
go with that though
and he got uh
got to get past cambodia first i don't
think so
let me see
yo yeah yo
it's it's so i'm so used to not cursing
that um
that i try not to curse
you know i don't know if you're sitting
there with your kids
i don't know if you're sitting there
with your parents just just flew in and
just hanging out with you um
i'm sorry this is just me it's just the
respectful nature i don't know what's
what's going on with you i don't know
who you're showing it to
and and i'm on my first impression to be
my best impression and be honest with
you all right so these dudes is in the
seventh round and this is one of those
filler fights but it's an entertaining
filler fight
these dudes going to land a bunch of
shots
they're going to throw a bunch of shots
and they're durable
um they're going to probably be there
for all the way through and it's pretty
decent you know so again we got kanaki
versus uh demises the minute demones
it's crazy
i i i want to see
what uh
benevitas does they say i like to watch
a boxing match early they rules clacks
to train to fight it
i think would open people's eyes
yo
if they change the rules of how boxing
used to be
until one guy you know quits
hollywood rules what's up with the final
super chat thank you brother king king
about the great work my brother can't
wait for tomorrow's show
jim said they're not enough laugh out
loud thanks as always
thank you so much let me let me just
briefly
talk touch on
the playstation numbers give you a sneak
preview and y'all think that's my topic
it's not my topic though
um
i told you
i told you things were spooky on that
side of the road and i told you what
phil and then was doing
ahead of time
that was changing how
these dudes see
um
their future so
i don't know man this two-prong approach
is crazy they just showed uh jerome
boots innis
i love me some boots paws actually i
love me some crocs but um
boots is definitely there
post up what up what up what up post up
that's right share it out let get let's
get everybody watching us let's get
everybody watching us
i'm getting over a cold right now still
got a little cold
so
but um yeah we almost finished with this
then we can get to the main event let me
see let me see
croc gang that's what's up bang bang
single street gang yeah show that i
don't know why they they did that like
you couldn't put a whole bunch of
exclamation points
yeah croc game
yo
all right so
i don't think keith thurman is lined up
for spence i think spins vacates i think
they i think they have a plan
be honest with you i think i think the
plan is this right
never said this to nobody
i think the plan is
if crawford
fails to step up to the plate
and
uh jamal vacates all his belts
and spence goes up
and start picking off these fighters one
by one over at 154 he drops his belts
down at um 47 and goes up to 154 and
start picking him off i think jamal
comes back from this back injury
um
i don't ever want to say a card fakes an
injury
uh i don't ever because that will you
know tarnish uh somebody who
i think is a reputable great uh
champion and i respect everything about
him
i don't think the card was selling
uh
would uh
i think it was beznackie
uh that uh jamal was fighting that was
his mandatory so i don't think it was it
was selling or whatever and they had to
come up with something i don't know but
i don't i don't think it's on him i'm
not gonna say it's on him um
well i think i think that's the plan
so
like earl has
options
bud doesn't have options who is gonna uh
broadcast bud fight zone don't want him
top rank don't need him
it's only the pvc is where he's at in
this this fight and i think bud
understands that so and then let's say
he does sign with the pvc and he does
find it like a three-fight deal he loses
let's say he loses just let's say for
the sake of argument's sake he loses the
spin spence becomes unified uh walt away
champion and you know he's gonna vacate
the next and just leave
and he's gonna leave everybody to fight
for these belts then you got boots there
that's ready to fight
you have thurman there that's ready to
fight you have danny there that's ready
to fight
um well oh no danny went up to 154 this
is danny's first fight at 1 54.
uh
so
that that pool of fighters is there
what wins do you pick out for bud
there because you know if bud signs a
three-fight deal with the pvc
and he loses to spence
and you say it's a rematch clause maybe
it's a rematch clause right but
spencer don't gotta listen to that he
can just drop the belts and be like
whatever go fight for the belt so
whoever i'll just beat you get out of
here and go up how many times was it a
rematch clause for floyd
and floyd's like uh whatever dropped the
belts
all right so it's contingent on you with
that with that belt the only person i
seen that forced somebody to fight that
rematch was deontay wilder versus fury
he made him fight him but i think that
had more to do with the wbc belt than
anything else
let me see all right kane
it's just us in here you kidding about
the [ __ ] right hell no i would have
showed you my crocs right now but i'm in
my basement
i don't i don't know
i'm not gonna sit here and lie i'm not
gonna cap i was just in a meeting the
other day and just talked about crocs
i'm i'm not
if you've never put on a pier
when you're in the store and nobody
around you
put them on it you tell me
just walk around
and don't tell me you're too hard you
too tough to put on some crocs
i'm tough as hell anybody to raquino
tell you right now i'm a tough ass hell
dude like i'm tough as hell like i smack
the hell out you
i'll rock some crocs though i'll rock
some crocs be careful because don't get
knocked out by the dude with crocs
god forbid
god forbid you you're arguing with a
dude in crocs and he puts his joints in
sports mode and go off-road on you god
forbid don't have don't let that happen
don't happen
thank you thank you moved upstate and
you got you some crocs thank you thank
you yeah he can't go to mtk and that's
right
yes hopefully just in time for the fight
yo
i
you can't say rolly rolly fighting uh i
i got blood i got blood if he fighting
roley
i got blood i got blood all day
oh word
there you go
yo i i got slides i got slides in the
house i had a pair i got a pair of croc
slides
don't mess with me man
they just make some good cushion on the
bottom of your feet man
the best thing in the world is to have
nice comfortable feet the worst thing in
the hat in the world is to have a pair
of shoes you ever had a pair of shoes on
you remember when you going to church
your mom's made you wear those shoes you
ain't like those shoes the shiny buckle
jumps yeah you don't front back you
dudes know what i'm talking about
had them hard bottoms on and you walking
man you had that face
don't lie to me man you ever had on a
pair of bad shoes you thought they was
nice i used to wear a pair of jordans
too i had uh what was the alligator
skins yeah yeah well no no iguana skins
the iguanas i said alligator skins and
jordans
they thought i had bootlegs right
the iguana skin joints
yeah i remember when they came out
yeah cherry shoes is definitely the
worst yo so right now
is we got one more round to go these
guys are still chugging along still
uh
pumping and dumping poles you know
landing shots on each other right to be
honest with you i'm thinking uh
dimensions
is um
winning the fight be honest with you
that's what it looks like it looks like
he's pushing
the the
the balance
but again kanaki is landing a lot of
good shots it's just the way he reacts
to shots is bad it's not like he reacts
to shots in a good positive way i don't
know you're gonna say like okay king how
can i react to a punch in the face
stoic
take the shot dip your head stay there
grit your teeth bite down on your guard
you know um
don't throw your head back you know
those those type of shots even when
you're turning with the shot don't
forcefully turn your head with the shot
too much because
it gives the refs uh an impression
that you was hurt so
that means you're not in control you
don't have ring generalship remember
they they they base it off for three
criterias and um ring general ship is
definitely one of them so you have to be
careful with that you know
you have to show a composure inside the
ring if you're not showing composure
inside the ring
they're going to vote against you and
them judges is watching everything you
do what up king but it was that's right
in the house there's pain what's good
baby
you say yo hunger brand shoes make your
feet feel like they got a contract
um fury fury's retired
from all indications and everything that
i know
fury's retired
fury doesn't
did this this what else is fury going to
do
stuff for fight anthony joshua and
anthony joshua's tied up with fighting
music
so anthony joshua's tied up with fight
music so that means that again tyson
fury has to fight again somebody he
probably doesn't want to fight what's
the worst thing in the world getting up
to go to a job that you don't want to go
to
the only thing that
that tyson fury has to the fight only
person is anthony joshua right and then
he beat all his contemporaries in this
area when he was retired he came back
from retirement and fought deonte he
went straight to the most fair dude the
smartest thing in the world is what
tyson fury did when deontay wilder was
champ
when anthony joshua was ducking him
he said i'm gonna go straight to the
fire
because win lose a draw first of all he
knew he knew he had better boxing skills
than deontay wilder i mean that's plain
to see
if i go in and i lose i just came off of
retirement i just came out of rehab
whatever they're just gonna write me off
whatever and i got a good check right
if i beat this dude then i'm that man
i'm that comeback king you saw a
completely different
tyson fury
after that first fight with deontay
wilder
excuse me he became a monster
after he beat him in the second fight
he is the biggest beast that he will
ever be right now
so what he wanted was anthony joshua
that biggest fight
in english like that that that fight in
europe would
the numbers would be sickening
absolutely redonkulous
so on god in them
what what who do you want him to fight
like
there's nobody for him to fight and
don't don't say andy woods and don't say
uh uh uh ortiz king kong ortiz
not not not nothing there it's nothing
there so
if there's nobody in his contemporaries
and don't say usic because
that's just like adding more layers to
the cake because i don't think usak um
i think lucex is a great fighter i don't
think he hits hard enough to keep tyson
fury off of him
i think tyson fury has a better jab
uh as far as big man go
he's a 300 pound big man with a jab and
a right hand
that's tall as hell like six seven six
six something wild like that
disgusting it's absolutely disgusting if
you ever been in a ring with somebody
that big and that's skillful
that's a mountain that you don't want to
climb
so
let me see
he said he'll only fight
if it's free for fans yeah
yeah tyson retired until little boys
that's right
yo um
me and attic is working on a strictly uh
uh uh
marvel
stuff i do weekly things with lords of
gaming.net so if you want to go to
loyaltongaming.net i do weekly uh
disney plus stuff and movie stuff
there um so you can check that out with
lord's minute uh we put a lot of those
stuff on on on the channel but there's a
ton of that stuff there and if you go to
lawrencegaming.net you can see that's
that's our website you can see
all the stuff that we talk about you
know it's quick burst stuff about um
superheroes and and what's coming up you
know the fight is over
i i really think it's uh dion says
won the fight be honest with you uh
kwacky was there he was absorbing punch
punishment position out punishment as
well so
i think i think the main event is next
and that's what's up that's what we came
to see let me see
what i'm saying
why would you want him to do stay busy
fights
i wouldn't want him to do stay busy
fights like why would you want him to do
stay busy fights stay be stay busy
fights get you beat
could you get in a rut nah you you got
to have meaningful things meaningful
things actually pushes that envelope
pushes the fighter to to greater heights
that added
level of fear with him fighting deontay
wilder in his comeback fight
you got one of the best versions of
tyson fury
you know um and he he showed deontay
that you know deontay had to have his
style up there too
all right so here we go
the fight is over
thank god
the beautiful ballroom brawl fight
and um
not to diminish anything that they got i
mean yeah it's good these guys can
absorb shots these guys can stand there
and they can give shots but pause
not not not
not what
i look for you know like i said
butterbean style you know fights that's
not what i'm looking for be honest with
you
look at that these guys then
through tons and tons of
punches ridiculous
no
immediately no i've seen everything i
want to see and i say no
oh um i didn't see nope yet so don't
spoil it for me
all right um i didn't see nope yet i'm
gonna see nope uh soon i just saw candy
man
the other day the new candy man uh the
the the what is it jordan peels candy
man
i thought it was dope i thought it was i
thought it was
um
what you what you expected
a good story
because remember candy man was a b movie
uh and then it you know was a hood
classic stuff like that
uh but actually
this one gave him a whole background
story
a whole
a whole
real
true
lore
for you to for you to to bite into it
it's it's really it's really different
it's really good
it's really good it's really good so i i
just saw candy man so i'm gonna see no
i'm a fan of jordan pill movies i think
you know uh get out and stuff like that
i think he does uh urban horror
really good um
so i can't wait to see this and i think
i heard that was based on a true story
nope was based on the true story so
all right so who do we have next
all right so these dudes back into the
ring they're going to tell us exactly
who won this fight and then we can get
on to to
what we came to see
but again oh and this dude is from
turkey that's what's up
let me see i'll tell you right now
as a unanimous decision
97-93
yeah i told you the anzac
yeah
he
he showed a level of control inside the
ring
he uh
gave as much as he as he received pause
um
it was definite definitely a good fight
for him it he looks
i always say
when you look at a round right
who do you want to be in that round and
that'll let you know
who won that round
so when you look at somebody at the end
of the fight
[Music]
that lets you know
who do you want to be you want to be to
do with the eye hanging out his head or
you want to be to do with the clean face
that you know get regular
the club you know do it up
yeah i've
ever since i'm doing this i've never
been
more a fan of hurry up get out of the
ring and let's get to the next fight
than anything else to be honest with you
let me see
must be getting old but these fights
have to start earlier first
on the east coast
no i'm used to i'm used to late night
like saturday is my my only day i
actually get a chance to relax and have
a good time so
no i i don't i don't care but just you
know eat your food you have a little
drink probably party afterwards because
these dudes go to the club after
so
you know this is this is good could you
imagine you being another country
and right now it's like four o'clock in
the morning
all right so
yeah so again i i i think this guy is
gonna be uh go right back to ballroom uh
boxing
and um
and then he'll get another win he'll
he'll stay churning he'll be a journey
man he'll keep churning and keep
churning and then hopefully later on
let me ask you a question
who should david benavidez fight
because everyone is ducking them
um he's he's he spoke about
andrade
and i think demetrius andrade
and
benavidez should fight
but i think demetrius andrade's boxing
style
um plays into the hands
of um
david benavidez
so
i really like i
going into that fight i would think
david benefit is should be the the
favorite
out of on going against andrade
but then andrade has this weird thing
about him that every time you turn
around
this dude is winning
right he has a weird style that it's
hard to quantify
and he definitely gets it done
i think jamal
it was like it was a period of time with
jamal charlo
and jamel charlo
they started out here and then jamal
had leapfrogged them a little bit
right now jamelle
is like
so far ahead
and i think it has everything to do with
canelo
tying up all the belts
at 160
and not
getting these fights
done how he's supposed to
avoiding the true uh fighters that he's
supposed to fight
fighting triple g again to hell for that
like what what the hell triple g not
fighting anybody like the top drawers
don't want to lose
to the to the hungry tigers
hungry lions
and i i think canelo stagnated the 160
pound division
fighting a bunch of meaningless european
fights
that
was
in his favor
and i think that took away and it robbed
us from a lot of amazing fights that
could have happened because could you
imagine
if canelo would have fought jamal
and andrade would have fought triple g
they would have had a round robin of
that
that that that whole thing happens
and then you say the winner out of that
fight each other then you probably have
uh andrade versus jamal or andrade
versus canelo or canelo
versus um
jamal
i mean just just a whole cornucopia of
good fights could have happened jamal
versus triple g
could you imagine that like we we've
been robbed of these fights and we
didn't get these fights because uh
canelo tied up all the belts
in this division and everybody is trying
to fight the the one cash cow
don't fight that one cash cow
go out and fight each other and these
dudes aren't doing that and that's
actually holding us back that's actually
keeping us away from the actual level of
greatness that we want to see because we
definitely want to see it like we have
this one possibility right now
with uh
spence versus crawford we have that true
once possibility that could happen this
year that should happen this year
we have a possibility with uh
uh garcia ryan garcia versus tank i
don't think that happens at all to be
honest with you um
but i do i do expect
haney
versus tank
to happen
i honestly expect that to happen i think
that will happen way before garcia
versus tank
i think garcia would wait a couple of
years before
that for for that to happen
all right so they they dragging it out
what what time we got here all right so
we might be looking at the main event
right now
we might be looking at the main event
right now let's see
and this is this is exactly what we came
to see
let me see let me see let me see what
else we have coming up we have uh
[Music]
i thought that we had uh
what you would call it like a boots
fight i think a boots fights coming
all right here we go yeah the main event
is about to start in a second
the first fight at 154 and he came in
light both uh jose uh benavidez came in
i think he came in at 153 and danny came
in at 152.
i think you know danny is pushing it to
be honest with you i think he's a he's a
natural 1 uh 47. danny's really a 140
fighter
to be honest with you i think he came
from um
a 135 so danny's a natural 140 fighter
and um
now he's going up
he doesn't have any snap on his shot
right now he's working with mitts back
in the um room with angel and he doesn't
have any snap on the shots i don't like
it i don't i don't like it i don't know
i don't like when
you don't have an intense
build up to to to your action
because how you train is how you perform
right so if i don't see you performing
how you training
you know um
that's that that that goes all the way
back to the gym
and and i guess that's how sean paul our
father felt that with porter he wasn't
performing he wasn't training and he
knew he wasn't going to perform in that
manner right
um i've been in enough gyms you know
i've been uh sparred with enough people
to know
that uh what you do in the gym is going
to translate in the ring what you do uh
sparring
uh jogging working out
doing everything that you're supposed to
do is going to translate in the ring
i'm a firm believer so if you don't do
all essentially if you don't do all your
sit-ups a body shot will find you inside
that ring to remind you that you should
have been doing your 500 sit-ups a day
and if you wasn't doing them you didn't
do them somebody's going to remind you
behind next time you're inside that gym
all right so
you got uh they they talking about danny
i think danny to me
danny is one of my favorite fighters win
lose a draw i don't care
you know i'm not to do with that record
and stuff like like you have an old
i don't i don't care if it doesn't
tarnish you for me it's how you how what
level of accountability you give
yourself in that ring
so and don't make no excuses don't do it
i just love how him and his pops is i
think i think that's huge i think uh
i think uh every man should teach his uh
his son
how to be a man and then make that
transition to be his friend
right because you could be a daddy but
then you make that transition to be his
friend
i think that goes a long way
that goes a long way
yeah you know you you love your kids to
death but you know at a certain time you
have to become a friend and i think i
think he's a good friend of his kid
i don't think he's a good trainer i
think he's a good friend of his kid now
though but he got him there though let
me see him see
we need to go back to the days when the
own meant nothing an average fighter had
a couple of losses on his record that's
what's up that's what canelo said that
they should fight each other ryan garcia
is a bad knockout waiting to happen he
stands straight up and he backs up
yo
i've told somebody that about ryan
garcia i don't like how he backs out
from work all right so when i'm saying
work right this is gym talk when when
you're working
and he steps out of work he doesn't
slide out or move to the side he steps
straight back with his head on a stick
somebody just and and that that fits for
tank
right that fits the tank take a slip
over boom throw the left hook right over
the top or throw that right hand
straight pow
crack them um i can see that happening
devin haney not too much devin haney
powder puff with the hands touching you
moving to the body he's gonna work he's
going to outwork you
um
and canelo saying that they should fight
each other
is another way of saying please leave me
alone
you go fight each other why
when floyd gave you the shot when you
were
nothing
floyd floyd was just being petty he just
wanted to take away
oscar de la hoya's cash cow because they
were trying to build you up remember you
was under floyd's
pay-per-view cards all the time oscar
kept throwing you under there kept
throwing you under floyd used you
strategically
to bring in the viewers
but
and he was building you up to knock you
out
so
well not knock you out but knock you off
pause let me see
okay that's about it right now um
so everybody's ready right now right now
get ready come out all right so they
showing jose benavidez uh work in the
midst with his pops
light light move move um i don't know
what they're talking about with his leg
injury i don't know about the leg injury
so if somebody knows what happened to
jose benovita's leg uh previously i
think when he fought uh
but you know they're saying something
about a leg injury and you know that's
when he fought but so please let me know
uh
what y'all what y'all know how his
brother david benavidez is dead they
call him the mexican monster the
boogeyman
the killer in the dog
oh he got shot
oh word and i was i was i was gonna say
that i just didn't want to talk out of
turn and i damn sure don't want to put a
gunshot on nobody right
um
wow he got shot in his leg and he's
still boxing
yo
how tough is these dudes
like yeah man these these these dudes
are tough man we had some tough fighters
like i was watching a lot of um
older fights i like i go back and i
watch a lot of older flights like floyd
patterson i'm a huge jack johnson fan
um i'm a um i like uh uh jack dempsey um
i'm a huge i'm a huge huge
boxing boxing boxing fan
sugar ray robinson is probably
the greatest thing i've ever seen
touch the ring like
the greatest thing i've ever seen
um sunny listening if if
if i ever had to be reincarnated
as a boxer
i would like to be reincarnated as sunny
listening
excuse me
sunny liston's jab
was like a lot of dude's right hand
like
y'all remember young george foreman his
his his jab was crazy
but sunny listening had skill and
technique and just power just
he he just became champion very old
in in in his reign and you know
a lot of stuff around that man but i
think sonny liston was probably
one of the greatest
monsters that ever walked the
heavyweight division you know very fair
dude
you know and then jack johnson
you know then and then joe lewis you
know joe lewis is
a freak of a man
all right so
right now
you got uh
is that danny coming out with ame maria
yep there's danny coming out first
which is kind of weird
so you got danny coming out first so he
gave up
whatever to to to come out first i guess
they flipped the coin
because being that danny's name is uh
headlining the bill you would think that
danny would come out second
and well i guess that's where they
worked it out at they was like okay your
name goes first but you come out first
i don't know
i don't know i i just find that a little
bit weird so he has a
uh
encrusted
mask and it looks like remember when
deontay wilder came out for the second
fight with tyson fury
it that's exactly what the mask looks
like so
that didn't bode well for uh tyson fear
i mean uh deontay wilder
so
i don't know man i don't know i hope he
doesn't lose back when floyd was
fighting de la hoya and pacquiao did you
ever
you ever thought floyd would lose to any
one of them
yeah i'm a huge wwe fan back in the days
he was shot twice what
paul
rockman no i haven't but again that's
entertainment on the rockmon fight
no i don't think boxing ever
returns to free tv ever i don't ever
think it returns to free tv oh no that's
what that was
benavidez that came in with the mask
yes okay so what he did was
he took danny garcia's
uh stick
you know danny garcia comes in with the
mask right so i automatically assumed
that that was danny garcia jose
benavidez is ridiculous
it is absolutely he is absolutely
ridiculous
that was funny
that was absolutely funny that was petty
that
wow
oh man much respect to you sir that's
exactly he come in with ame maria and he
came in with that oh let me get these
dudes out of here don't be peddling your
sex in my chat get your sex
out of my chat
let me report these dudes
get out of here
remove
how they start getting moderated boy
removed
let me see what danny coming in with
hold on gotta get that stuff out
okay danny didn't even come with a mask
he come with a wrapper
what danny doesn't come with a mask
oh man
it's free in mexico yeah
yo i honestly don't know if danny has
the hunger i don't see the the beast in
his eyes
and what he has to realize right now
jose is coming to fight
jose is coming to fight don't don't get
it twisted
this is the most tame
danny usually comes with that mask i
don't know man
i i i'm a highly i believe in rituals
like
if you if your ritual is you having this
mask on
you
we're not switching up nothing
you know um
i believe in that stuff like i'm
believing i'm highly superstitious i'm
i'm an athlete what the hell you you're
supposed to be i guess
you know um because you you look trying
to look for symbolisms or look for
something and comfortability to make an
outcome you want to have a level of
certainty you don't want to believe that
everything is up to a whim right so you
want to have a level of certainty that
you train the same way uh you drink the
same juice uh you did this and to get
this result you know
so
uh guys believe in these rituals and and
they believe in these habits
he doesn't have this mask on i don't
know man
uh okay so we're getting ready to start
the fight
who got jose benovita put one in the
chat
who got danny garcia put a two in the
chat
after we get that in then then i'm gonna
tell you exactly who i pick
uh in in this in this fight
danny's 34 jose's 30.
oh man
jose got a 71 inch reach danny got a 68
inch reach
danny is uh 50 uh
5 8 and uh
jose is 5 10. jose is younger with a
longer reach
taller
could be hungrier
young boy's crazy
so danny
got danny danny danny and a lot of ones
one ones
oh definitely might have some hot tea of
course
yo he definitely deserves a beating for
that mass yo he definitely deserves a
beating on god in him
all right so
man after seeing bud
you know and but had a little bit of
difficulty with jose at first
right so if we think that bud
is better than danny and
i believe that bud has better boxing
skills than danny i think but uh brings
more to the table than danny i think bud
can cross that line
uh better than danny i think danny
invested his money well
so that doesn't help him as well either
i think uh
oh they got my referee steve mills in
there
i mean steve willis
oh he looked like a frenchie come to
life like a french human frenchy
um
uh
man
i don't ever pick against danny
i mean i picked spence against him
that was about it was the last time i
saw him
50 50 fight i wish i had a coin right
here to flip that coin
but you holding my feet to the fire
i think danny can catch him off a
counter
i think danny throws that uh
no look left hook and catches him off a
counter
would i be surprised if jose
outworks him
yeah
i'll be a little bit surprised
but again
he spawns his brother david benavidez
which is the bigger guy
uh
man man man putting your money down
online
boy oh boy
danny is a big name to be that's a big
that's he he going big game hunting
danny
i gotta rule with my kid man i gotta
roll with him when losing drawer man i
love this guy man i love danny i gotta
go with danny
oh man
don't make a fool out of me danny don't
make a fool see this was when betting
with your heart this is when you and
you went too deep you haven't been in
too deep pause this is it man unanimous
decision danny
yeah danny popped it i don't got jose
nah nah
[Music]
yo that's yo suicide that's 100 facts
that's 100 facts two years off
two years may rejuvenate a dude
hmm
dude might be rejuvenated he might get
up into the situation and be
he drink he drank and he swam in the
lake of minnetonka you understand
you probably know how to breathe again
you know i don't know
i don't know man
i know he better let those hands go
all right all right let's
get ready get to it
all right let's get ready get to it
pause
yeah yeah i don't know jose chess looks
soft paul
all right so they in the center the ring
let me see the first one to throw a jab
danny
you can see the height
but um
all right so jose gives up his height uh
he goes right into danny danny is
greater when a guy when he's the counter
puncher so he needs to let uh jose lead
all right so they're in the center of
the ring they're exchanging jabs danny
goes to the body and he slides over
and moves over to his right
i mean moves over to his left and he
throws a overhand right then he does
uh jose slips under slips a jab throws a
jab danny again
jabs up at him
and he's trying to to bring jose in they
clinch in the center of the ring steve's
breaks him up
jose and then he's back in the center of
the ring
exactly in the middle of the ring
okay danny try to catch him with that uh
left hook counter like i said that left
hook pull counter that he does so well
oh right hand from jose danny goes
straight to the body
uh-huh so again um jose is doing a nice
good jab and he's he's trying to measure
him for the right hand danny is smart
going to the body
very very smart going to the body take
away the legs
of uh jose
jose does a 1-2
and uh danny slips out the way and they
reset they back in the center of the
ring uh so i see jose's strategy he's
trying to throw overhand right to catch
danny um he's jabbing him
very long jab from jose danny's going to
the top and the bottom with his jab uh
touching the body and he tries to catch
him with an overhand right but jose
jose is mocking danny he puts his hands
down he teases danny he steps over danny
does jose goes right back to the jab
um
[Music]
all right so
danny again oh jose throws a left and uh
overhand right and a left hook and he
goes right back to the long jab he's
catching danny with the long jab and
he's trying to catch him with the
overhand right out of that long jab
uh danny needs to have sharp movement
he's not having sharp movements as i
want him to have he's going to the body
so his plan is to go to the body of jose
jose is to go over the top
danny catches jose with a straight right
hand
it might be an easy night if danny can
string together some punches
jose is trying to get danny out of his
game
with my mocking him
all right uh
jabbing is a jabbing contest right now
danny does a one two to the body
all right and jose goes right back to
the jab
and he's trying to walk him in
you know
and danny is uh
going right to the body they just both
miss overhand rights
danny throws overhand right round is
over
again
i can see the strategy of both
uh jose is trying to land that overhand
right uh to keep danny honest and danny
is going to jose body to sap his
strength to get him to his weight class
uh because remember this is danny's
first time at 154 so he's trying to get
acclimated to the weight class doesn't
want to fill the shots right now let me
see
anyone thinks about danny look much
smaller yesterday
danny vegan now
marco ran and robbed again against both
these deals that's what's true hit that
like button for show but we you know
they definitely hit that like button we
got 35 likes and 18 watching 19 watching
20 watching that's what's up let us
let's keep going man let it grow let it
grow let it grow to what it is when the
call-ins happen
that's when we're gonna be really
popping
let's go let's go
see remember hit that cash app it
definitely works that's a real one
that's not a troll i'm not trolling you
guys y'all guys be scared that i'm
trolling you
all right let's see let's see all right
they're back in the center the ring
round two starts
all
right so
you you have uh
jose trying to throw the jab over the
top okay that's cool
um danny okay so danny is letting his
hands go a little bit more
he threw three punches but they was all
blocked by jose
a one two three
danny is backing up
all right jose is trying to track him he
threw uh jose through three shots but
they were all missing
excuse me
all right so jose
oh overhand right by jose he caught
danny pretty good shot
uh-huh
you can see he's using his length
um and and i think danny would look
small in this weight class towards a lot
of people because danny is not a big guy
all right so
you know he's fighting the naturally
bigger guys in this weight class because
he got out of that weight class that's
his punch carry that's what we want to
see
you know this is punch carry here
all right so again jose is stalking him
you know throwing uh jabs and he's
catching punches jose has a wide stance
right now does that play into danny's
hands he went underneath to danny's body
and jose is trying to mix it up a little
bit more now
so he has a wide stance he's coming into
danny he has a high guard wide stance
then he's shooting his jab uh danny is
uh giving him faints and he's going up
and down so he's varying his jab in
levels high low high low
and he's trying to catch him with the
overhand right
uh but jose blocks it
so you know jose is stalking him again
and he's uh touching him with the right
hand danny is pulling and
pivoting out of his uh
out of his distance
jose's distance that is
danny goes underneath and catches uh
jose under the rib as he spins out
and he's spins out again
all right so he throws uh three shots
and he spins out
out of danger
all right good body pull counter to the
body shot
jesus that was a hell of a shot for
danny
danny catches him again with the
pull counter shot
and he's going right back to jose's body
but jose is doing the majority of the
stalking that we're seeing here
all right nice beautiful right hand i
mean jab from jose
nice jab from jose i mean the more
comfortable that he gets with that jab
the more dangerous he's gonna be to be
honest with you all right so he's just
flicking his shots out there danny is
working the body three shots
and um he's gonna have to be patient
bigger class
oh good shot after the bell from
benavidez was a right hand uh but again
uh i i give two rounds to danny so far i
think danny did the most uh work that's
there
but uh jose has been utilizing the jab
and a decent right hand here and there
he's doing the majority of the stalking
work so uh does the pressure get to
danny does he feel that he can't hurt
him you know those things right there
may change exactly how you see the fight
later on to be honest with you what is
the
judges looking for
yeah colin's gonna be dope
i don't know who javonte fights next
he should
yo yes reagan dow used to have the best
pull counter to the body
he would drop you from a body shot and
that's that cuban style remember i told
you i love cuban fighters to the death
man i think their style is incredible
all right so jose looks fresh
all right round three starts danny looks
fresh
i think the fight starts in round four
around five danny is on his toes right
now
all right he looks he looks like he's
into it now remember danny's a slow
starter in every fight all right jose uh
catches uh danny with a nice jab
i think that jab starts to tell after
the fourth round
from jose
you know so okay so danny is circling to
the wrong way he's circling uh towards
the jab hand of jose
and now he just pulled out and circled
right back towards the right hand which
is smart
all right and danny's throwing the jab
but danny's moving a lot now
so he's trying to keep uh jose from
landing the jab and making him use his
legs
all right
so uh jose throws a 1-2 and he catches
danny with a straight right hand he
catches danny with a straight overhand
right all right so he has danny in the
corner danny uh catches jose with a
straight right hand
jose looks a lot more comfortable than
danny at this moment
um
and
right now
they're both landing heavy shots
so but benavidez looks more comfortable
in in in this whole exchange danny keeps
stabbing him to the body with the jab
right now danny goes right back to the
jab right hand
i think the height is is messing with
danny to be honest with you right hand
to the body uh hope benavidez
um
then he goes right back to the jab
high and low high and low he's tripling
up the jab
all right so danny is not trying to lose
the jabbing contest
to uh jose and he takes the right hand
he gives right hand to jose's body and
he steps over gives another right hand
to his body and he steps over
but jose is still stalking him
and he's stepping over danny's giving
him a lot to work with
for him to come in all right pause oh
danny throws a one-two to jose's body
but jose is still walking him down
so it looks like the bigger dude is
actually taking the shots
um
i don't know i don't know this is this
is this is hard to see because either
he's a hell of a poker player all these
shots really don't bother him and he's
just trying to wear danny down
all right danny's they're right back in
the center of the ring danny's throwing
the nice jab
uh
okay danny throws a nice one two three
and they kind of blocked but they still
are landing shots
right
oh
those body shots is killer boy from
danny danny throws a one two and he goes
straight to the body
one two and he steps over
jose is allowing danny to work
all right
and uh he can't hit he can't hit danny
have two seconds left in the round
and right and danny catches them with
two
two body shots at the end
again i gotta give it to danny i gotta
give danny these three rounds because
danny's doing a lot of bodywork and this
round was the most that he did movement
but jose looks the more comfortable
he looks like he has the better energy
all right he caught danny with a couple
of shots here in that round
but again
danny went right back to his sequence of
work
let me see
mma of boxing
yeah danny yeah benavidez is looking
unboxed unbothered
thank you so much lightspeed
mma boxing always boxing for me i'm a
boxing boy i respect them nato
um i don't want to fraud you guys and
give you an mma fight that i don't know
too much about to be honest with you i'm
not gonna do that
i could never do that i can never do
that
all right so
here we go again
round four started i told you the fight
should break out on round four right
uh at some point in time benavidez gotta
say to hell with it and chase danny down
and just go for broke right
all right so danny has the high right
hand and he's jabbing right so he looks
like uh me too can box like
i'm my first boxer
all right so right now benavidez is
still tracking him and still jabbing and
still coming in but his elbows is open
while he's doing that so he's giving up
the body and he's crunching down so he's
giving up his height and he's giving up
his body to danny and he's shooting his
jab
all right so danny's able to go under
all the shots he did a one-two and he
stepped over
and you you have uh benavidez again
stalking him with an open guard
hands is open when i say open guard his
elbows is open his hands is open and
he's sticking his jab out walking him
down
that gives a uh uh a
thought of being open when you're not
you have to be very athletic to pull
this style off and uh danny is smart by
hitting him in the body
hit his hands hit anywhere that you can
hand hit because what he's trying to do
is just trying to score so danny is in
naturally the philly style
you know shoulder up jab
hand across right here across blocking
your chin blocking your face
you know this hand does all the work as
far as blocking
all right so again jose goes right back
to jabbing
oh straight right hand from danny caught
him
caught uh jose
when he didn't expect it
all right danny should not fall in love
with his power at all it's not ready yet
but he throws another right hand and
catches uh jose jose can pull back
uh and catch danny out of pocket
all right again
danny's still there philly style
so he goes right back to the jab to the
body
it's a nice jab to the body
all right oh oh
so he missed danny miss and jose caught
him with two uppercuts and caught him
with a strop uh left hand inside he
called danny danny has a great chin
thank god but that overhand right and
that jab i think danny's a little bit
buzzed right now
benavidez landed a couple of good shots
in that round then he goes right back to
the body and he jabs straight right hand
to the body then he goes right back to
the street right hand to the body and he
goes right back to the jab
jab and uppercut uh-huh pull counter
under from danny
benavidez throws the right hand and he
throws a jab he's reaching with his jab
and he's reaching with his right hand
danny's touching him again he's flicking
the jab up and low
and he's going to the body again you
have eight seconds in the round
oh danny's uh throwing the one twos all
right danny is doing a lot of work he's
letting his hands go danny's actually
showing the best box and i've seen
danny's show in a long time he looks a
little bit more comfortable in that
round
i guess he feels that he took a couple
of good shots from um jose and he feels
a little bit more comfortable i think
they need to tell jose to step it up a
little bit more and what he needs to do
is he needs to go back to his height he
needs to start throwing long uh straight
right hands and following with left
hooks to the body
yeah wild punch from danny definitely
boxing video game oh we having that ebc
uh boxing game that's coming out that
looks pretty good
which is the best discipline
um i think they're both uh really good
uh i i can only talk for boxing for
myself i never trained in mma i used to
do karate when i was younger
let me see let me get rid of these
all right round number five started i'm
trying to just get rid of this stuff out
of the chat
all right so
he's throwing uh three shots
jose is throwing a nice jab
and danny's on his toes
he's uh looking like a philly boxer
right now
but jose did just like i said
one two three now danny is doing some
crazy stuff in the middle of the ring
and that was weird
he almost got me he almost got his head
punched off mocking jose benavidez
but danny's uh jab up and low
jab up and low
danny goes right back to the body with
the right hand
steps over
good good one two one two three
from danny
um jose is mocking him throwing a right
hand and not really doing work he throws
a right hand over the top to danny
catches him with the jab catches him
with the right hand danny catches jose
with a right hand
but it seems like
danny can't hurt jose
you know with any of these shots you
know
and jose keeps throwing that one jab
so it's a very clean jab but he needs to
follow it up by two more shots
danny keeps going to the top through the
bottom
to the top to the bottom
all right
then he bounces back out
oh right hand left hook from danny
all right
uh jose catches danny with a right hand
and a long jab then he bounces back out
of there and jose tries to catch danny
danny's walking jose and he pushes jose
down to the floor
jose gets up and pushes danny back
they call the timeout
referee tells him to go to his corner
calls him time out the holes on one
second you tell them both of them calm
down
and put it right back in i like steve
willis i think steve willis is a great
referee to be honest with you
all right
danny back on his toes this is the most
i've seen danny on his toes in a while
let me honest with you
one two three from danny
and jose catches him with a right hand
as danny turns to spin out
all right danny goes right back to the
jab oh danny shoe shined him
all right and jose got upset
all right and the round is over so which
i don't know what shoeshine is like that
and he did that to jose's body and he
spun out and he had a shot of right hand
uh we have 27 people in here hit that
like button we got 41 likes that's
what's up
uh tony harrison love tony harrison i
think tony harrison is a good fighter i
think he has one hell of a style
and you know boots boots is definitely
in the building
20 uh 29-0 with 27 knockouts he's the
next dude he's that next dude
and
you got uh what's that uh
sugar hand
uh
and
and here we go here we go we have ooh
guys there
man benavidez david benavidez is there
he got the happy sad face because he
knows his brother's losing
what round are they in i think uh oh
rayquan is there rayquan is sitting
there shout out to the chef
so we're in round six right now
yeah he beat bud in the amateurs yeah
but that's that's back when they both
was like lightning behind i was like
what it was a 135 something like that
i think bud beat him one time too i
think they i think there was even i
think they did one-on-one something like
that
okay so danny uh danny's jabbing jose's
starting to walk him down now
oh danny missed with a wild uppercut a
right uppercut all right jose is uh
coming in stalking him throwing the jab
throwing the right hand danny hit him
with a one two to the body
all right so
oh
oh david i mean david jose caught him
with a left hook inside
he's starting to walk danny down
a jab
and he's he's standing in danny's pocket
then he hit him with a right hand
buckled him and stepped off
then he did then he went right back to
the body with the one two
all right jabs up top
right hand over the top
all right
jose is throwing jabs
all right they're right there
danny throwing jabs to the top into the
body oh
jose missed uh two shots an uppercut in
the right hand then he's uh moved out of
the way daddy tried to hit him with a
right hand
uh huh jose hit danny with a left hook
to the body nice little [ __ ] to the body
too
uh-huh
all right so
[Music]
danny uh
tried to shoot the right hand over the
top
there might be a right hand to end this
uh jose caught danny with the uppercut
and danny spinned out the way
all right
right hand to the body from danny
and then he's standing in the pocket
then he does a one-two
ref tells him to keep it up because he
did hit jose on the hips
all right oh danny tried to catch him
with the overhand right danny is
standing in now he's not moving back and
jose needs to capitalize on this he
needs to make this counter shot
count because danny is in the pocket
all right
there we go right hand over the top from
david danny throws a left hook
they're landing shots in the center of
the ring danny is backing out and david
goes right back to a nice jab i mean
jose goes back to a nice jab so used to
david benavidez
and danny goes to double left hook
which both is blocked
one two three from danny and a right
hand straight to the body
right hand straight to the body
round is over we're going into the
seventh round right now
excuse me
let me see
yeah he's committed to the body
let me see danny throwing a few bad
punches yeah he is
who's the next big boxer from new york
city um
if you count in uh jersey i'm i'm gonna
say shaquar stevenson
uh i think shaquar stevenson is
uh one of the bright spots from brick
city gotta give that boy that brick city
love
tony harrison is there he's talking
right now
yeah jose needs to stop talking and he
needs to definitely put in that work and
cut it out man because
you know
you're going to the seventh round so in
the seventh round you already
right now to be honest with you i'm not
gonna lie to you if i gave him one round
i gave him one round but i give all
these rounds to danny to be honest with
you a rough uh uh um
the judges is not going to sit there and
constantly keep giving rounds away i
mean unless it's blatant
on what i'm sipping on tonight uh a blue
hawaiian i made a blue hawaiian
definitely dope
all right so they back
jose tries to catch him with the
overhand right he does actually catch
danny with the overhand right the second
time he threw it
but this one was in close it was more
like a slapping overhand right and he
goes right back to the jab danny is
committed to the jab and danny's
committed to the body in this fight so
he's throwing the jab up
david catches up david jose catches him
with an overhand right again um like i
said
they gave so far an unofficial scorecard
uh
garcia all around i've i've given them
all around too i think the work rate is
a lot higher
i think the quality of shots that he's
landed is a lot better but i do like
jose's jab if if you want to talk on
something that's positive i gotta say
his jab is positive he's just not
following it by a right hand he doesn't
have his brother's tenacity in following
up shots with the right hand
he falls in love and he crunches his
body
and he doesn't give everything that he's
supposed to give
you know he has to work his way inside
pause
oh
danny
catches uh jose with a nice right hand
but he backs off
and he goes right back and he goes to
one two and he's up against the rope he
springs off the ropes
jose is jabbing danny to the body
danny goes to a sloppy overhand right
but then he goes straight to the right
hand to the body again
he's jabbing
right hand
danny is doing a lot of the work
so danny's oh nice left hook from jose
danny goes right back to the up and top
up and bottom jab
all right
oh
nice short right hand from
jose nice jab
danny miss overhand right
all right here we go again they back in
the center of the ring daddy is sweeping
the right hand he's trying to land the
right hand as much as possible jose
keeps landing in the jab very sharp jab
one positive i gotta give him is that
danny lands the right hand
jose backs up
and jose goes right back to the jab
danny goes to three shots
one to the top two to the bottom
and
oh danny catches him with a one two
three
tries to catch it with a left hook at
the end of the round
again
round is over i give it again to danny
uh i think danny is putting in a
a workmanlike uh performance
i didn't know what to expect from danny
off for the two-year layoff but uh he's
uh surprising me with what he's showing
he's dancing on his toes
uh does he look like he has the hunger
i wouldn't say that but i don't also see
uh jose pushing him to be honest with
you i don't see jose pushing him to that
next level to give you that uh vintage
uh danny garcia but also danny's a
little bit older as well so
you never know but again
jose is not forcing him to fight
yeah he can't train
yeah imagine danny with a hell of a
trainer
like a dan goosen
oh my god
all right so they come back out
you can see danny a little puffy around
the face
from the jabs
from the jabs and and the the right
hands
but again
all of his work that danny was doing was
to the body
and all of uh jose's work that he was
doing was the majority
of those jabs
to the face and you know
and the overhand rights in the slight
left hooks that he do get a chance to
land here and there
nothing does does the gunshot uh
you know limit his mobility
probably so
you know to be honest with you because
he's not
able oh he catches danny with a one two
three
uh he's stiffened danny leg up a little
bit right there
yeah
danny got off his toes real quick
real quick
all right
so there you go
all right jose's sweeping
for shots and it's
not clear danny nice left hook to the
lever
nice right hand to the body nice right
hand over the top but jose digs under
and catches danny with a couple of shots
under danny comes back with overhand
right
and they're right back in the center
danny tries to land overhand right again
knowing that keep in mind danny's bread
and butter is that left hook
oh and he catches him with a one two
three
uh jose goes back to the jab danny goes
back to one two three slips underneath
through one two
all right he goes to a left hook and he
slips under jose catches him with a jab
all right so jose is back in the center
of the ring danny goes right back to the
jab to the body
i think jose is bugging out by giving
danny the body but they're exchanging
body shots right there
all right they're in the center right
there
all right
so they're both jabbing
danny went to the head to the body
and then he throws a right hand to the
body
left hook to the body right hand to the
head danny and he spins
uh jose tries to throw a left hook then
he catches it pivots and throw a jab
uh then he's moving along the ropes and
he's catching and countering catching
and countering
all right
jose is uh throwing the jab danny throws
a one two
and goes right back to the jab
he's on the inside throwing a left to
the body
right hand to the body
oh
jose catches him with a right hand over
the top danny ate it
then he ate that shot danny's upset
uh-huh danny goes right back to the left
to the body
very very good
oh good one two and danny goes right
back over the top with the right hand
and then then he shoots the right hand
and goes right back to the body he
catches danny with a great overhand
right shot and what does danny do danny
doubles down and does more work
this
he may not be the same exact danny
but this danny is giving you exactly
what you expected from a former champion
right now you give he gave him you've
given him what he's supposed to how's
the condition to hold up so far the
condition is fantastic i'm not even
gonna lie beneath benavidez looks slow
and stiff and he's throwing a lot of arm
shots not punching with any real power
that's right big man he definitely isn't
punching with real power let me see jose
can't blame anyone because danny is now
standing right there for the work i miss
coda left you know what koto did have a
wonderful left hook to the body but he
always set that left hook to the body up
with that jab he'll throw that jab and
then when he he'll faint the right hand
and then he'll slip and dig it up under
the liver
beautiful shot i love miguel cotto's uh
left to the body always a setup shot
beautiful
we in round number nine of 12. i don't
even know why it's 12 there's no belt on
the line
should be a 10 round fight i don't know
what the hell is going on here
all right so
back in the center of the ring um
danny right now it's really danny's
fight to lose danny has won every round
on my scorecard uh danny's throwing a
triple jab
danny looks like the sharper of the two
the fresher the two uh
jose like you said he's throwing nothing
but arm shots to be honest with you the
jab is nice
it's flickering and he throws a right
hand he's he's he's actually working now
he's actually caught danny with four
shots in a row that was pretty decent
um
a couple of body shots a right hand
but
it's not like he's really committing
and danny's right there holding his
pivot
right in front of him to be you know to
handle that work pause
all right david keeps uh
doing this lunging right hand
and he's throwing the jab danny's right
there
throws a right hand over the top steps
over and throws a left
danny throws one two
jose catches them up and under
they're throwing punches with each other
in the middle of the ring he's working
danny's body now and he tried to catch
danny with the overhand he tried to
catch denny with overhand again
all right
oh right hand and he catches danny flush
with the right hand catches danny with
the left hook with the
very flush danny's dropped his hands
all right they're right there that was
definitely something that he can work
off of be honest with you
this is right here danny's right back to
going back to throwing more punches see
that's the only thing any success that
jose does have
danny
goes back to working
jose has to build off of his success
and he's not so okay so he goes to the
top
he goes to the bottom jose
shoots the right hand over
and then he goes right back to the body
jose jabs him pretty decent and throws a
right hand to the body
but a lot of these shots is just
flicking shots a lot of arm shots
nothing with force nothing with power
you know um you expect at some point in
time for jose to buckle in and to to
to go at danny
all right
so danny
is right there
and danny is stalking jose danny has
jose up against the ropes
uh
this is a weird uh
position
and the round is over so we're going to
round 10
and i can't say i gave jose any of these
rounds so far
let me see colonel's missing he's a
cotton demon what the hell is that okay
kodo or demon that's how you say cotton
d
he said yo you keep calling the number
it's a busy cycle it's not that time yet
bro stop being funny gabe
stop being funny gabe soon as i put the
number up
first we won't be in this room
okay
so know that so when the phone work
i'm gonna keep flashing the phone number
works it doesn't work right now so don't
don't do that don't do that don't be
having anybody with the five five five
five five don't do that
come on now you know i have something
like
1 800 call king you know something crazy
all right there we go round 10
did jose wake up did he take no doughs
did somebody give him some coffee
oh
danny is throwing right hands like it's
the second round
danny is bouncing on his toes his
condition is holding up so then he
wasn't bs and that's when he was saying
that he was working out throughout this
whole two years
he catches uh jose with a right hand
over the top they clinch
and jose is punching him in the back
you know
it's all right you have a strong jab
from both of them
in the center of the ring
danny's on his toes again
jose throws a strong jab
all right danny's throwing the jab
throws the right hand to the body
all right um
so they again
right back to the jabbing contest
and danny's danny is now taking the lead
jose is bouncing out
they have switched rows now so danny is
stalking
and jose is on the defense
so again danny's trying to land to the
body
i think you know um jose needs to learn
how to stop taunting and how to start
fighting more
because that's that's a huge problem i
mean if i was in this corner i'd be
hugely upset
be honest with you because you know put
that energy towards fighting
you know danny's thrown to the body
let me see
danny goes up to the top yo that was a
beautiful sequence danny did two jabs to
the top miss both of them went to the
body with the jab and came right back up
with a double jab to the top so he threw
five jabs two to the top one to the
bottom and two back to the top and threw
a straight right hand over the top
danny's going right back to double and
triple in the jab
it's ridiculous how i've never seen
danny jab this much in my life
to be honest with you
oh nice hook under the bottom uh
benavidez lands are left hooked on danny
danny spins out he lands a right hand on
danny danny spins out
all right
so
he's throwing jabs
and danny goes up and goes back to the
bottom body with the jab
right hand with the jab
from the right hand to the body
sorry
right hand over the top from danny
right hand over the top with danny with
a one two
all right danny does a one two three
one two three
danny
danny does one then he does the two
spins out left right
very easy
another round for danny um i honestly
gotta say this is this is the best i've
seen him look in a while as far as
um not saying focus i'm saying as is
boxing ability
and you know some people's tune-up is is
another dude's uh
hard fight right so maybe this is looked
at as uh danny's welcome to
154 tune-up is he ready for jamal hell
no
jamal is the champion and tony harrison
is definitely a dude that danny do not
want right now
but uh danny is you know he's looking
pretty decent
let me see
what does this fight say about jose if
danny's been off for two years said a
lot about them
it says it says a lot about um
jose
it says jose
uh needs to start looking at tate to
realize where he's going wrong
and working on throwing them hands
because
i tell you how you work in the gym
is what you're gonna show in the ring
danny does a one two three again
and steps over
you know and and this is is round 11.
i thought it was the 12th round
because i'm expecting some fireworks
from jose i thought jose was going to
bring it and jose isn't bringing it
you know i think that i think that
gunshot affects his his footwork because
he's not able to close the distance as
you would like him to close the distance
all right so jose is throwing multiple
shots he's stalking then he's coming at
danny right now he's throwing one two
threes
and he's actually coming at danny
danny's doing a lot of backing up right
now
all right and he's able to stay out of
jose's range
by spinning around him
and stepping over
and then he throws a right hand over the
top
danny does a one two
danny goes right back to throwing the
jab one two
right to the body
and jose goes right to the jab
one two from danny one two three four
from danny in the center of the ring
that's uh
left hook right hand
left hook
then he spins again
throws a jab
one two
from jose
he tries to dig an uppercut
danny stands there
and jose
again is reaching with this right hand
again
this is this is
you know you have to make opportunities
for yourself and i don't think jose is
making opportunities for herself
danny is making opportunities for
herself there's nothing there danny just
goes right back to fundamentals
all right
there was a roll counter that uh jose
didn't pull on the royal counter he had
danny uh actually execute the right hand
but he didn't roll counter with it he
didn't catch it roll and counter he
didn't do it it wasn't there and you
know danny's thrown right back to the
body
that's uh nine seconds in the round
sharp right hand from danny on a spin
out
round's over then it goes straight to
the body again another round that i
can't even say
uh jose benavidez is actually doing
anything to
uh put danny in danger well there goes
danny's a beautiful family his sister
his mother
his uh
i think that was his
daughter right so this is around 12. do
you think danny's gonna do something to
jeopardize anything in this fight no
he's not he's already up so why would he
do anything to jeopardize this fight no
yeah
does the fight say about them hold on
hold on
yeah jose can't bring it jose hasn't
been bringing it jose has uh
jose has disappointed me
i really wanted to see this is a
crossroads fight for both of these
fighters and
jose is acting like you know like he has
it in the bag like
like he was
winning some rounds or something like
that
danny put in the work
i i i think uh um jose brother somebody
was supposed to yell at him man
you let him know man you're absolutely
blowing this whole fight
all right so here we go
jose is reaching danny's just
backpedaling dancing hoes danny is not
going to do anything to jeopardize this
fight at all
you know so you know
danny is back to jabbing stepping back
jabbing stepping back
jabbing
you know jose is jabbing walking him
down but
danny's going to the top and to the
bottom
to the top and to the bottom look at
that
to the top to the bottom is it with a
jab and and i expect this jab to be
throughout the whole round to be honest
with you
excuse me i expect it i
i i see danny uh
winning this as a whitewash to be honest
with you because all this guy does is
every time danny lands a good shot he
looks at him he goes no you didn't hit
me uh yeah he did hit you
yeah he is working
it's absolutely ridiculous
then he goes
right hand left hook then he slips under
steps over
right back at it
danny moves over
danny's sticking out his tongue at him
jose is uh
mocking him
jose is standing in front of him daddy
lands four crisp shots
this is stuff that you do on a heavy bag
when nobody is around
you know this is this is when your train
is not there you do that stuff and he
caught jose with a left hook uh coming
in and again
you know the crowd stands up but
danny throws a one two three
and he steps over
and you know they're talking to each
other while they landing shots but it's
danny that's landing all the telling
shots
you know
there you go
danny goes one two three and he pulls
back
steps out
jose keeps throwing the jab and he keeps
reaching with the jab
all right and danny throws a one two
three goes right to the body
and spins out
daddy goes daddy's keeps shoe shining
them
then he's stepping over danny's actually
throwing his hands in this fight
you know if y'all asked him to throw his
hands in the aerospace fight
he didn't but he's throwing his hands in
15 seconds now
then he's going woohoo
he throws four shots
he's dancing
i've never seen danny dance like this
danny threw four shots this was the best
danny garcia looked in a long time his
stamina was there he had everything that
you know was going on for him i can't
lie it was a great performance um would
i love to see him go for the knockout
i don't think he was hurting him i don't
think he was hurting jose and that
manner to go for the knockout but again
um jose wasn't able to do a lot of
things and that has to do with that
other man that's inside the ring with
you
so i'm going to give danny his props he
he went out there to do exactly what he
was supposed to do and that was get that
win
and your man got that win so shout out
to danny for going to get that win
and um
making uh jose look pedestrian
in doing so
angel about the max a whole wow you
crazy
come on dookie kicks we ain't gonna do
that to that man even though
i understand exactly what you're talking
about
he definitely might
let's just get to the official
the official fishing so i can give you
all that outro but let's let's let's
let's get to that official fishing
yo
tune in to iron lords tomorrow i'm gonna
as soon as they give me the stats and
i'll tell you exactly that danny won
even though there's no doubt you know
the judges have to have some something
have to crazy had to have happened
um but um tune in to in-laws podcast
tomorrow where
we have a situation happening we have a
hell of a guest
um that you would definitely love
uh he's
integral to a lot of things happening
uh later on
so uh tomorrow at 1 p.m eastern standard
time tunes iron lords uh
channel iron lords podcast
as we
talk this gaming
and talk what's going on with all these
games
i'm gonna actually tell you guys man i
think each and every last one of you for
rocking out with me
always when there's big fights the king
is there when there's a party to be had
the king is there
you know uh the professional fan
you know you tune in we're gonna talk it
up
you know i i just love fights
and
that's all i'm going to do i'm going to
talk fights i love fights i love i love
exactly what i'm saying i love
all types of fighters to be honest with
you
i tell you my my one of my best yo to my
my best is like a cuban versus a mexican
fight i get both of my favorites in one
style
like you're like
it's it's dope
but then you know you have some european
fighters that like uh joe kalzaki
loved that guy i think joe calzacki was
a an incredible beast of a man
um
and then you have uh some black fighters
that i thought that you know i told you
my my list of black fighters is
ridiculous
um
you'll be surprised who's in my top 10.
you'd be absolutely surprised
all right
what they called it a draw one dude
116 and 112.
117 and 111.
let me tell you something
that
judge that called it a draw
needs to be fired
needs
to
be
fired
never this is that's the reason why
dudes don't like boxing to this day
that's the reason right there
there's absolutely no way i don't maybe
you got cataracts in both your eyes
you're nearsighted and farsighted
maybe maybe you asleep the whole fight i
don't know what you was doing maybe it
was on your phone on twitter i don't
know maybe you was writing in the wrong
stuff maybe you you you mixed up the
names on your skull card maybe you had
it messed up
maybe you was giving danny rounds and
you was taking away rounds because he
was beating him so bad i don't know what
is going on
but there's absolutely no way in hell
there's absolutely no way in hell
you call illicit draw ever
you definitely need to have your license
revoked you need to be uh
somebody needs to put an investigation
in on that judge man let me see
there's always one he was thinking about
the previous fight still throw that
judge and reference that's right throw
him in the bushes man that's absolutely
crazy but let me give you all that outro
man
thank you guys for rocking out with me
see y'all next combat talk with the king
[Music]
it in the ring i gonna send a contract
i'll knock his contacts out you will
feel mice trying to take a viper ain't
no competition in the ring decipher
cause i'm spitting financial swing of
fire talking pickled peppers make them
pay the piper cause i might go look like
a rude discussion and deflate your chest
like a fool production you'll be talking
like you want a new concussion to do the
custom attitude adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sound which i will serve
heaven's tipping moving like a tire
swerve out here acting bad thank you
michael jackson even got his one and
only homie capping you a phony homie now
you owe me action have him sinking tony
tony tony braxton and they all want to
talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant momma got hands so
i'm ready for the tension i'ma leave him
red you could dance to redemption
[Music]
you